mi hanno sempre detto quando finirai la
scuola rimpiangerai tutti i momenti di
libertà che avevi diventerai subito
grande una donnina che dovrà badare da
sola a se stessa il suo futuro dovrei
imparare ad essere indipendente
responsabile e mi raccomando eh non
farti mai mettere i piedi in testa
perché il mondo è lì fuori è cattivo
soprattutto per te che sei una donna
posso dire che ansia non ho ancora
vent'anni e ho già tutti questi pensieri
a cui badare
Sì ho detto bene Non ho ancora vent'anni
sono Raffaella ho 18 anni e da meno di
un anno ho finito il liceo scientifico
quadriennale attualmente studio
ingegneria al Politecnico di Torino e mi
sono trasferita in questa grande città
partendo da Pulsano un piccolo paese
della Puglia e ho solo 18 anni
Vivo in un ambiente Dove sono tutti più
grandi di me c'è chi frequenta il
secondo terzo anno di università chi sta
per laurearsi alla magistrale o
addirittura che sta facendo un dottorato
e non vi nascondo che parlare con
persone più grandi e vederli muoversi
nei miei stessi spazi mi fa un certo
effetto
sapete quando ero piccola ero in
paziente di diventare grande Pensavo non
vedo l'ora di avere 18 anni così potrò
decidere io cosa fare della mia vita
senza che i miei genitori mi dicano No
non puoi senza che qualcuno mi ponga dei
limiti
E questa sensazione Penso che un po'
tutti l'abbiamo provata nella nostra
vita chi più chi meno ma oggi le cose
sono cambiate e mi chiedo e se in realtà
non volessi crescere
e come se quella voglia irrefrenabile di
essere catapultata in un contesto tanto
affascinante quanto sconosciuto si fosse
trasformata in natura nostalgia del mio
passato
svelo un mio piccolo segreto non l'ho
mai detto a nessuno da quando sono fuori
sede torno giù per le vacanze dalla mia
famiglia e c'è una cosa che faccio ogni
volta Prima di ritornare qui a Torino Mi
fermo sulla soglia della porta della mia
camera e fisso la libreria che ho di
fronte proprio su quella libreria sulla
prima mensola in alto a destra c'è una
scatola colorata e diversi album di
fotografie
mi prendo alcuni minuti per guardarci
dentro
vedo susseguirsi Momenti Preziosi della
mia crescita mi vedo cambiare tra uno
scatto e un altro e ritorno a
quell'istante in cui i pensieri erano
altri le priorità erano altre che
probabilmente anche i desideri
Ovviamente in questi album ci sono anche
foto molto più imbarazzanti
ma sono del parere che sia importante
ricordare che ogni fase della nostra
vita ha una sua bellezza intrinseca e un
suo significato ed è importante cogliere
la capacità di trovare tutte quelle
sensazioni quelle uniche cose che ci
rendono felici
chissà cosa penserò fra un paio d'anni
quando rovistando in quella scatola tra
le varie fotografie ce ne sarà una di me
su un tappeto rosso davanti ad un
pubblico visibilmente emozionata a
raccontare ciò che sente
Io vedo i miei vent'anni come un
presente immaginario presente perché mi
trovo qui oggi a parlarvene e
immaginario Perché quasi Non mi sembra
possibile essere arrivata fin qui in
così poco tempo
Wow
Ho già fatto tutto questo e quando avrò
seriamente vent'anni cosa farò chi sarò
un gran cambiamento È già avvenuto nella
mia vita dalla realtà del liceo mi sono
catapultata nel mondo universitario
dicono tutti che andare all'università
sia una liberazione puoi decidere tu
quando iniziai a studiare per gli esami
se due mesi o due settimane prima se vai
e arrivi in ritardo alla tua lezione
nessuno ti dice niente puoi decidere
addirittura se seguire la lezione da
casa o non seguirla proprio a meno che
la frequenza non si è obbligatoria e
soprattutto
nessuno Controlla che tu stia seguendo o
prendendo appunti
Però ora vi chiedo di fare un piccolo
esperimento
ripensando al vostro primo anno di
università In quanti hanno provato
questo senso di liberazione di felicità
sentitevi anche liberi di alzare la mano
bene
alcuni non l'hanno alzata io in primis
infatti vi dico che io mi sono sentita
disorientata smarrita ho detto cavolo E
adesso come si fa Come faccio a sapere
se sto facendo bene
non reputo il superare gli esami l'unico
è il giusto metro di valutazione quello
è soltanto il risultato finale Più che
altro Bisognerebbe concentrarsi sul
percorso che ci fa arrivare finì su
tutte quelle sensazioni belle e brutte
che ci fanno vivere
vivere
che concetto strano proprio su questo
pensavo l'altro giorno
usciamo realmente della nostra vita chi
ci dice che stiamo vivendo cosa si prova
realmente nel vivere e ancor più Esiste
un modo corretto di vivere e uno
sbagliato
mi domando spesso se io stia vivendo la
mia vita nella maniera giusta ma giusto
secondo chi secondo cosa
e se avessimo scelto un'altra strada
forse non avremmo avuto mille pensieri
per la testa
ma saremo realmente felici come lo siamo
ora o Saremo solo più felici
a vent'anni cosa si deve vivere cosa ha
la priorità lo studio o l'amore
viaggiare oggi o programmare il domani
lavorare o seguire la filosofia del
carpe diem Dopotutto come ti dicono
spesso ma quando ti ricapita di avere
vent'anni
sono l'unica però che pensa di star
sbagliando tutto di star sprecando il
proprio tempo di star gettando all'aria
il proprio futuro
l'unica che si domanda di chi mi devo
circondare di persone che mi ricordano
che ho già 18 anni o di coloro che mi
ricordano che ne ho solo 18
sono l'unica che pensa al fallimento al
caso estremo in cui desideri e sogni
possano venire a spazzati via
Ogni quanto vi fate queste domande
raramente a volte può capitare spesso
sempre
non ho ancora vent'anni e già devo
indossare quella che io chiamo la
maschera della felicità un bellissimo
ornamento che nasconde tutte le paure le
ansie le preoccupazioni di una vita che
corre veloce sapete io ho sempre odiato
mentire e indossare questa maschera non
solo con gli altri ma anche con me
stessa più più volte È veramente
difficile da sopportare
ma nonostante ciò dobbiamo continuare a
sognare a essere determinati davanti le
sfide che ci si pongono
le mie scelte non sono mai state le più
semplici forse anche largamente diverse
da quelle che in molti prendono per pura
comodità Ma perché non ho mai avuto
paura di essere da sola o di lottare un
pochino di più per ottenere e
raggiungere ciò che volevo A volte
sembra di vivere una Corsa contro il
tempo in cui fermarsi è uno svantaggio
imperdonabile e quella visione deviata
che la società inconsciamente si impone
Ma qualcuno di buon cuore potrebbe dirmi
che invece è necessario che io mi fermo
un attimo
respiri e mi guardi attorno
che è bello il piacere di potersi
ascoltare di sentire di essere reali di
essere vivi
ma in maledettamente difficile trovare
un momento di pace di tranquillità
quando si hanno mille pensieri per la
testa
e così in questi anni Ho escogitato un
modo che riesce a rasserenarmi
praticamente sempre
quando vedo che tutto intorno a me sta
andando storto Ho
semplicemente paura per il mio futuro mi
nascondo
letteralmente
inizio ad immaginare un posto dove
nessuno mi possa vedere per scappare
solo 5 minuti dalla frenesia del mondo
corro verso il mio letto chiudo gli
occhi e mi metto sotto le coperte così
so che se anche dovessi aprirli nessuno
riuscirebbe a vedermi
le cose però si fanno un po' più
complicate quando un letto in cui
nascondersi è una coperta dove
nasconderti non ce l'hai
Allora ho pensato ad un'altra soluzione
qualcosa che potesse aiutarmi nei vari
momenti della giornata
Quando andavo a scuola Ero solita
mettere un libro sul banco così che nei
vari momenti di ricreazione oppure nei
vari intervalli potessi leggere non solo
però per il piacere della lettura ma
perché ricevere domande su
interrogazioni e compiti imminenti mi
stressava da impazzire quelle classiche
domande che ci si fa 10 minuti prima di
una verifica hai studiato Cosa hai
studiato come hai studiato dal libro
dagli appunti o addirittura perché lo
avessi fatto Chi ti dà la voglia di
studiare
una miriade di ansie e di Preoccupazioni
in più per le quali la lettura riusciva
a darmi conforto serenità e pace tanta
pace
mi piacerebbe che tutti i problemi
potessero essere risolti così
ma la realtà è che la vita di ognuno di
noi è costellata di inciampi battute
d'arresto errori Ed è proprio attraverso
questa esperienza che si impara si
cresce più di ogni altra cosa si trova
la propria assenza
e forse la strada che ci porterà a
trovarci a trovare noi stessi passa da
questa sala e da questo tappeto rosso e
sono fiera del coraggio con cui Oggi vi
ho parlato di tutti i miei pensieri
anche di alcuni miei piccoli segreti e
non mi interessa se ho detto qualcosa di
sbagliato o di banale per alcuni perché
Ricordatevi che ho solo vent'anni Anzi
18 Grazie
[Applauso]